[Music]
mavis is in portland oregon hey mavis
what's up
oh hi dame such an honor to talk to you
you too how can we help
yes i have one simple question we
recently purchased term life insurance
uh through vendors and but a friend of
mine
she's in the insurance business now and
she
highly recommends to get a you know a
whole life insurance or versus term life
i don't you don't
a whole life life insurance agent said
you should get whole life i'm shocked
well no she just she she works for a
different
insurance company i told her i said you
know i just got
um term life with you know vendors for
dave and then she's like you know i said
let me tell you all this good thing
about whole life
it just sounded so good um drug dealers
want you to use drugs too
they do yeah and a lot of them
are users too they make them sound so
good yeah
so good yes yeah so okay what can i
you obviously know we stand the whole
life insurance sucks
now how can we help you you're not going
to convince your friend because she
sells it
right i i guess my question is why don't
you recommend
like what's the that's a good question
that's
an excellent question okay whole life
life insurance
is somewhere in the neighborhood of
20 times more expensive for the same
amount of coverage
so for in other words if we take a
hundred thousand dollar policy
uh um or our 250 000 policy and it was
five dollars a month for term
it would be a hundred dollars a month
for whole life
okay okay so now we have established
statistically
based on your age with the probability
of your death at your age
what it costs to cover your life should
you die
we know five dollars will do that so why
do they charge 100
well the other 95 goes into
a savings program inside the policy
called
cash value she probably mentioned that
to you
it builds up cash value and they say it
builds up
equity like owning a house where term is
renting well it's not at all
that's a mixed metaphor and it's
absolutely a lie okay so here's what
happens
you got an extra 95 you're being charged
that's going into
ins to the inside of the policy with
cash value
now here's how cash value works get any
whole life policy out and look at it the
first three years
your cash value build up is zero
okay so what happened to your 95 dollars
it went to a month by the way not a year
what did your 95 go to it went to
commissions
and extra profits for them after three
years
it accrues nationally at an average of
1.2 percent
then when you finally get past those
three years and you finally get past the
idea that the
rate of return sucks and it finally
builds up some money now your 250 000
policy has a 20 000
cash value in it you have a savings
program inside there
you die the insurance company pays
the face value of 250 000
what happened to your twenty thousand
dollars you paid extra for they keep it
so you have a savings program at a bank
the first three years
they keep all your money after that they
pay you one percent
and when you die they keep your money
that's whole life life insurance
that sucks it is the payday lender
of the middle class it's how all the
towers in the skylines of every city are
life insurance companies and banks
they didn't make that money themselves
santa claus didn't build those
you built them america this is the dave
ramsey show